you're gonna feast on this one conceptuality is something other than
itself there's been a change in the image of thought that's what it is
that's what it is the internal structure but soon as an utterance slips from the
mouth it's divorced from the subject when you think of the terminology of
decentering that was associated with Derrida and this is very clearly an essay
where he says decentering that sort of decentering move has been the move that's
what I'm responding to I am not the guy who's decentering the subject or
decentering culture or anything that I am saying given that all of these folks are
decentering they face a problem and it's a problem that they don't recognize right
that they have not come to grips with you know and and that's to me what's I think
you're quite right it's like contextualizing this in 66 at a moment
where you know the US Academy is just hearing for the first time this idea of
differences without positive terms and this sort of and he's like you know this
is what's been going on in the French Academy for a decade and I'm responding
like he he is I mean he's I think in starting off from the point of what's
cutting edge in France in the mid 60s with a kind of critique in quotation marks you know
the sort of a critique of that but it gets heard and certainly received right like the reception
was Derrida is the guy who says the subject is decentered and there is no truth and it's all
play and it's like that that's exactly none of those things are true yeah he doesn't say any of those
things right right well it's also the case I mean I would also say like having taught this multiple
times like I I kind of slogged through the stuff on structure like I didn't I mean it was hard for
me it's very it's very dense it moves very fast the substitution of centers for some you know centers
for center like all of that stuff was very hard honestly it presupposes having read grammatology
you know because it's it's clear that he's just cribbing his argument from grammatology in really
short for and and the thing that I read in the bio is like he literally wrote this essay on the flight
like over to because he was like a last minute add-on to the conference like I said he wasn't a
big-name guy in 66 he was just a rising star and I think like someone bowed out at the last minute
and they added him in and and on the flight over he wrote this and he just kind of that first four
pages he just kind of cribs or summarizes really fast his grammatology argument and then really fast
does you know Levy Strauss again really fast you know he doesn't it's not the usual careful
you know parsing out that Derrida does this is like the this as an essay this is probably not
one of his best essays even though it's yeah I think by far the most read essay it's forceful for
only like 15 pages yeah it's short you know I mean like I don't see any gaps in the in the movement
in the first four pages I don't I don't see you know I was actually because tight yeah it's so tight
every single move just follows carefully from from the previous one and yeah it doesn't have
the sort of you know like if if he if he were giving this the attention that he would one of
his longer essays then you're right like a lot of these moves then would probably have a chapter or
two sort of that's right they'd unpack you know fall yeah unpack the thing and follow it through like
six or seven places and then come back around but at least for my mind this makes it it's easier to
follow because I you know I can I can it's like silly it's like syllogistic yeah it's far more
syllogistic yeah and that's just a little bit easier for me to follow yeah I mean and I do think
he lays out again I started suspecting this in the last few readings but in this case it became clear
where like you really do get a sense of his his values like what he values like what deconstruction's
value is like on page 282 where um you know and these are the kinds of claims that by the way starting
with this claim because this is the kind of claim that people don't hear about um from Derrida and
he's talking about you know cultural anthropology like any science comes about within the element of
discourse it is primarily a european science including traditional concepts however much it wants to
struggle against them consequently and this is the part like whether he wants to or not and this does
not depend on a decision on his part the ethnologist accepts into his discourse the premises of ethnocentrism
at the very moment when he denounces them and this is the line where it's so explicit this necessity is
irreducible it is not a historical contingency, right? It's not like it just happened because of
Lévi-Strauss's fuck up or even because this historical moment, like it's like this is an absolute, right?
necessity. I mean, that that's a really strong claim, and it's also, for me, and he does this in
Grammatology in ways that are much clearer when he's talking about ethnocentrism. He's talking about
metaphysics. Like, yeah, yeah, we usually don't think of those things as the same thing. We think of
metaphysics as this weird sort of philosophical airy stuff and ethnocentrism as this, you know, like
bias based on where we come from. It's like no, metaphysics is ethnocentrism. Like, it's not
it's not like a different terrain of questions. So, so the critique of metaphysics is not in this case. It's
not simply a philosophical lofty conceptual thing. It is a cultural bias, right? Like, that that's
the the larger target here for Darada is what does one do when one recognizes, you know, ethnocentrism
to be a condition of all discourse that we produce? Yeah, you know, well, I mean, I think it's worth, I mean,
especially your claim that this is not a contingency. This is a necessity. I mean, trying to to walk through
why that is the case because, you know, for him, like the the historical event that is not a contingency, that
had to have happened and was, I think, you know, I think he puts it differently in other places, like
it's always kind of playing out to one degree or another but just sort of really comes to a four at
a particular historical moment, right, is the rise of ethnology itself. And to say that like, look, the rise
of ethnology itself requires the discourse, requires the presumption of ethnocentrism, ethnocentrism
precisely because at a particular historical moment the ethnocentrism of European thought can no longer
um be so blind to its own uh its own relative place that it is not simply the discourse and then be
able to say, all right, well then we need something called ethnology to be able to account for this
plural plurality, but that then to to to move from that position of ethnocentrism which would then have
to include all of the metaphysical um uh language, all the metaphysical apparatus that allows this
ethnocentric um uh worldview to permeate and evolve and and operate um for ethno for ethnology to emerge
out of that. It has to emerge out of that discourse, out of those assumptions, out of those presumptions. So
even though it's turned on itself, like holy shit we need to start counting for difference, it can only
do so by mobilizing the the language, the presuppositions that it is at the same time critiquing and, you know,
sometimes borrowing from, you know, this quadrant to critique something in another quadrant or even when
it gets really close to each other, like using language to critique language, um yeah, but I either
way that I mean, I think that's why it's necessary. It's not, you know, just like some historical contingency
that it just so happens that that the west did this now. Like, you could imagine it could take, you know,
millions of years for this to happen or, you know, it could have happened all within, you know, like Cicero
talks about ethnocentrism and so do a lot of the sophists, but it just doesn't kind of click in the
same way that has the the same kind of ripple effects, um, but well and it's I think it's also
precisely because we don't think of metaphysics as part of ethno, you know, that right, that metaphysics
even still for those of us who understand we still see it as these kind of transcendent series of
philosophical values. And it's like no, those transcendent philosophical values are ethnocentric.
Like, that's, that's, that is the constitutive element of of the ethno is, you know, so so I think that that's
that's part of it. Like that's it. That's I to me at least a really just important lesson that the
critique of metaphysics is because there's a way in which I I just get the sense like my colleagues in
an English department will be like, oh yeah, critique of ethnocentrism, I'm down with that. Critique of
metaphysics like that's some airy lofty abstraction thing that like theory wonks do and it's like no,
they're the same thing. Like, literally literally the same. This kind of critique of ethnocentrism I'm
not sure everybody would love because it basically says that you're culpable in it regardless of your
intentions or your scholarship or your work. Like you have to be like ruth is a relentlessly attentive
to your own culpability in these dynamics, right? So there's or or not. It doesn't matter or not, right?
It doesn't matter, like, but but any in terms of one's culpability for sure. No, no, but any any presumed
ethicality or objectivity in this case from the perspective of the ethnologist is just, you know,
fraught with all these complications which I think is that that's where it's I mean at some level it's
like faced with the difficulty of ethnocentrism of whatever I produce, the discourse by and large
tries to figure out how you can be less ethnocentric, right, right, or a little bit less or a little bit
less you know voraciously ethnocentric right like that's the telos and this is an early version of you
know post-colonial i mean it's post-colonialism right and and the claim here is you can't be less
yeah like yeah there's no different less you can be differently but you can't be less right like and
so that to me like that's in in some ways i feel like that's a claim that still hasn't gotten
adequately heard right like it's because i think there's this still sense this sense of like well
if you're definitely ethnocentric you're trying you're being a little more ethically of a of a good
guy you know if you're like aware and that's what that's where i said you know what i the pr the
premise uh that i i mentioned a moment ago where we get Derrida's values where he says right after
the passage i just reading you know that this necessity is irreducible it is not a historical
contingency we ought to consider all its implications very carefully and i mean i think that's what he's
pointing to like that has huge implications if if you really are constitutively really strongly like
it's a vicious circle um but if no one can escape this necessity and if no one is therefore responsible
for giving into it however little he may do so this does not mean that all ways of giving into it are
of equal pertinence and this is where to me here's your statement of what does Derrida value that we
actually talked about last time in terms of the critique stuff the quality and fecundity of a
discourse are perhaps he's got to put in perhaps there right are perhaps measured by the critical rigor
with which this relation to the history of metaphysics and to an inherited concepts is thought yeah here it
is a question both of a critical relation to the language of the social sciences and a critical
responsibility of the discourse itself it is a question explicitly and systematically it is a question of
explicitly and systematically posing the problem of the status of a discourse which borrows from a heritage
the resources necessary for the deconstruction of the heritage itself a problem of economy and
strategy like i mean he says to me that's a pretty straightforward way of saying if you don't
explicitly address the problem you are doing a different kind right like you are not rigorous which is to
say if you're not actively in our terminology we'd say if you're not consciously aware yeah right now
he's not going to say conscious awareness because for him i mean one of the things that's great here is
it's repetition like thinking is repetition right like um so it's not a question of simple conscious
awareness but that that's the rigor is is a question of explicitly and systematically posing the
problem of the status of a discourse which borrows from a heritage the resources necessary for the
deconstruction like you have to explicitly write about that problem you know which is another way of
just saying anytime somebody asks you why does Derrida write the way that he does you just point them to
this passage right yeah i mean that's all the hesitancy with all of the qualifications with all of
the quotation marks and the parentheticals and uh the faux signatures i mean it is he's being rigorous
and explicit which also means he has to be incredibly tentative and say like look this do not presume what
i am saying goes one way i and i have to be able to show you it goes at least in two ways at the same
time yeah yeah i mean he's he's being rigorous about explaining what rigor looks like which is kind of a
difficult thing on the next on the next page so for instance so what we skip there is a page where he
uses the idea of the sign and Levi-Strauss's attempt to deploy the sign to critique metaphysics and he
shows but the sign is always a sign of so it's already always implicated whatever in metaphysics
and then on 284 um this example too cursory examined is only one among others but nevertheless it
already shows that language bears within its necessity of bears within itself the necessity of its own
critique now this critique may be undertaken along two paths or into manners i mean this is where
for me style like two styles once the limit of nature culture opposition makes itself felt
one might want to question systematically and rigorously the history of these concepts
this is a first action this is deconstruction is what he's describing right like this is a first action
such a systematic and historic questioning would be neither philological
nor a philosophical action in the classic sense of the words to concern oneself with the founding
concepts of the history of philosophy to deconstitute them is not to undertake the work of the
philologist despite appearances is probably the most daring way of making the beginning of a step
outside of philosophy which is difficult more difficult to make than everybody thinks the other choice
which i believe corresponds to Levi-Strauss's in order to avoid the possibly sterilizing effects of the
First one I'm not sure about that word sterilizing there, like what the the sterilizing effects of this
First one consists in conserving the old concepts but treating them as if they're methodological, right
Like, and and that, I mean honestly I feel like that second move is what everyone does, yeah, like
everyone, I mean in our field, in the field of rhetorical studies, it's like I recognize that these concepts that I'm
bringing to bear are not adequate and they have a tainted origin, so I'm just going to say
they're here, like for instance the emphasis on heuristics rather than method, like there's that there
was that whole conversation, it's like let's not make it a method let's call it a heuristic and it's just
a way of kind of sort of softening, yeah, in a sense the the the concepts that you're using, it's like
these aren't these absolute and and that's where I feel like there this critique today, this critique
in '66, like still resonates today because they're not going to show you about for just one second, but
I'm still listening, sorry. That's all right, it's like they're not going to show you, you can't just
declare or or it doesn't do much to just declare that oh my concepts are softer concepts, right, it has
to it has to be a direct questioning. Well and I think today you see a similar um issue but almost in
reverse, like with people like Barad where they almost refuse um their metaphysical lineage and
create new concepts that solve all of the problems of our metaphysical presuppositions, for example, like
intra-action, right, where it's it's designed to remedy all of the potential humanist suppositions about
inter, right, it's intra because right it's affecting each other and each person each relata is
constitutive of one another, right, so it's like it's almost like um instead of just provisionally using
um these inherited concepts, some scholars just reach all the way to the moon, they're like we're going
with something brand new that's never been seen before, yeah, right. Well there's a sentence there
that's perfect for that where he says um the step outside of philosophy is much more difficult to
conceive than is generally imagined by those who think they made it long ago with cavalier ease
and who in general are swallowed up in metaphysics in the entire body of discourse which they claim to
have disengaged from it, or there's another quote where he says turning the page on philosophy usually
amounts to philosophizing badly, right, and that's that's the that's the idea of the new concepts thing
it's like right exactly you know you recognize that nature culture nature and culture aren't
particularly good concepts, that they're fallible concepts, so what do you do in Barad's case, you call
it nature-culture, nature-culture, right, and it's like well I mean and you think ah I've gotten rid of
you know I've gotten rid of that series of problems but I I will also say like that's a tactic so
for instance for me like in in the style thing like I don't want to distinguish between thinking and
writing but I'm going to, so I'm going to do thinking-writing, right, it's the same kind of tactical move
the difference would be I think I understand that to be a tactical move that does not accomplish the
end run around the problem that I want it to, that I have to revisit that as a tactic
uh and problematize that tactic, whereas I do think that she thinks that well if you jam the words
together we're solving the problem then we're then we're no longer in the realm of metaphysics because
there's no opposition anymore, yeah, right. And yeah which is I mean it's it's obviously a little
reductive on Barad's part and that's part of my critique in the dissertation, but what's
almost more interesting is just the reception of that broadly speaking in the field and elsewhere
where everyone's just like hell yeah nature-culture man interaction right right like I can't believe
somebody has finally solved all of these pesky you know oppositions and binaries you like the way
Barad is done, so it's like clearly people are looking for a resolution to these problems
right but that's the problem yeah that's that's what they're not right yeah that's their that's
their point is that like yeah everyone wants a way out everyone wants to turn the page everyone
wants to go to the next new concepts and that's the Heidegger problem too yeah right like the the
I mean you know listening now to the Denkin dialogues as we uh or whatever I remember we
called it the Heidegger files, um but listening to that now that's the Heidegger problem too is that
like look here's the real dispositional problem for this stuff is you have to stop thinking about
solving the problem and you have to start thinking about inhabiting it differently it's just a
different dispositional orientation into these right and and that's the only thing and and so what
you lose in that is a sense of a kind of moral priority where it's like I'm doing the right
things like you're not doing the right thing, you can't do the right thing, you can try to do something
meticulously different um but is it just a different it's a different way of doing the same thing
that's the only game so i've got two responses to these i have a response to each one of these two
ways i'll start with the second one first just i mean the the sort of the move from um uh the method
to the heuristic and that that move that the one that was kind of wants to just soften method and be
like well it mostly works or it's an approximation but we know that there are exceptions that kind of
slip through the cracks but within the domain that i'm talking about you know it works well enough i can
cap you know like it's like Newtonian physics i can build a great car i know it's not sort of adequate
to the universe because you know i start speeding it up or slowing it down or making it hotter or colder
it all sort of goes away but it does a good job of explaining you know how to make a car to me and
that that is an odd version of heuristic to me in so far as it is just like a softened method where i i
think of heuristic far more like just inventively first it's like no it's a if it's a tool it's not
it's not a um it's not a disclosure of the well perhaps in the Heideggerian sense it is but it's not
just a a vision of the world or it's not a window into a world it's an intervention into the world that
remakes in some kind of way that heuristics are are inventive and from that perspective i don't know
what other option there is you know and i actually turn to like uh Deleuz and what is philosophy like
what else are you going to do other than make concepts like philosophy is the production of
concepts and nothing else and that doesn't mean that those concepts are just sort of you know
at their hubristic level they're um they're they're they're um um totalizing views of the world and at
their more modest level they're sort of like softened views of the world like no concepts are
empiric or are empirical they are little like empirical machines that go out into the world and
they remake the world them like themselves and the world so that that's the response to the second
one the one that you know is deridocious yeah is claiming like here's what levy strauss does and
here's why it's problematic that levy does it this way levy strauss does it this way and of course
you know the better option is option one which is to make that courageous very difficult requires rigor
and explicit attention of a way out of philosophy and like i you know it it at the end of um
the the the top paragraph the one that starts at the bottom of 281 and then spills over onto 282
and it's like like this is you know this you know Nietzsche Freud and Heidegger all kind of imagine
themselves as the last metaphysician but they're all trapped in this circle and they can all get
trapped in the circle differently because i mean isn't it interesting how they all kind of critique
each other for being the last metaphysician and then i just like wanted to write in the margins in
there like so we should go without saying that i am doing this exact same thing to them that i'm not
claiming to be the last metaphysician i'm just showing a different way of inhabiting this that
that circle and reading good chunks of this i think that's what Derrida is doing but then i read this
first path that he offers i'm like no he wants to imagine himself as the last metaphysician who's or at
least the one who can give birth to the overman who's sort of like pointing the way out of metaphysics
and this is by the way this is Rorty's Richard Rorty's um um critique of Derrida in his book um
contingency solidarity and uh ironies like Derrida's doing the same thing to um Freud Nietzsche and
Heidegger that he claims they're doing to each other and at a certain point you just have to be
comfortable operating within metaphysics but with it but you know it's still kind of them being
like recognizing that there are different ways of making metaphysics do a thing do its thing
although i mean a lot hinges and for me in terms of my reading this essay a lot hinges on that
there's that one sentence where you say like i mean it's true so each of these folks critiques the
previous folk for previous person for performative contradiction right they say they're moving
outside of metaphysics but what they do keeps them trapped in metaphysics right then it's one could do
this you know Heidegger regarding Nietzsche with which with as much lucidity and rigor let's hold
on to that part too like as much lucidity and rigor as bad faith and misconstruction as the last
metaphysician the last platonist one could do the same for Heidegger himself for Freud or for a number
of others and this next sentence is to me the key sentence and today no exercise is more widespread
right like so what is he saying there is he simply describing a phenomena of like you know this is what
We do, or I tend to read it as this kind of eye rolling, like, yeah, and this is the, this is just
this is the game everyone's doing this thing now. That second reading is interesting if let's keep in
mind he then proceeds for the next 10 pages to do exactly that to Lévi-Strauss, right? I mean, he does, he just
says he shows performative contradiction in Lévi-Strauss. So to me, the question is how do you read
that? How do you read the fact that he began the essay by setting it up and saying here are the
conditions for a performative contradiction? It's the easiest game in town, everyone can do it, right?
And here I'm going to do it with structuralism and the biggest name guy in structuralism, like
right, exactly. Like, I, I tend to read that as just sort of a, like, you know, see, one can do this, right? It's
not, it's not rocket science, and it's not, that's why that's where for me I tend to say that's why it's
actually not a critique of Lévi-Strauss, you know? It is because what he's done is he's prefaced the
whole critique of Lévi-Strauss by saying critique as in performative contradiction is the easiest game in
town. It's it's the necessary condition of all discourse trying to push on the totalizing logic and then
here I'm going to go, I'm going to go do this. But I began that by saying
nothing, no exercise is more widespread. Like, I mean, to me, it's a kind, that's where I'm like, it's an essay
that undermines itself, right? It's a, it's an essay that kind of erases the value of the critique, the
negative intervention or or even the desire to claim that there are two paths, right? Yeah, it's like no
there aren't. I mean, that's that's where that end move, right? The end move of there are two paths you
can go by, the two interpretations of interpretation. But it's like no there aren't, no, you know, well, I mean
this time reading the the sections on Lévi-Strauss, it just felt less like a critique to me in that
you know, in much like is the way that the first reading of Signature Event Context feels like a
critique of of Austin and then we go back to it and you're like, there's a hint so much there's not so
much of a critique here and in many ways this feels like look he's he's showing he's he's setting this
up and he's using Lévi-Strauss as an example but not as an example of someone who like does it in
spite of his hubris but as someone who like recognized a certain um uh uh function of the
nature culture like explicitly relies on it, recognizes a limitation of it, and then struggles
to kind of try to to deal with it and and in many ways like is just dramatizing or animating
that um that you know the self-critique of of metaphysics by the running through of metaphysics
and Lévi-Strauss is pretty rigorous and careful and he is and and Derrida is just sort of like
showing how he's being rigorous and careful and that's why it does exactly what it does in fact
in many ways in virtue of the rigoring care that Lévi-Strauss gives it yeah I mean I think he likes
Lévi-Strauss like I agree with you but but there are those like for instance and this is exactly the
problem of the heuristic methods question is the brick allure engineer yeah so levy strauss does
does they all love the bricoleur, right? Like, and but I mean and Derrida's critique is the bricoleur
is a vacuous concept because for it to work it has to maintain this idealized notion of an
engineer, right? Who's not working, I mean the bricoleur is working with the tattered remains and just
grabbing from here and there, you know? We're the dismantling the what is what is the Audre Lorde like
dismantling the the uh master's house with the master's tools, oh yeah, kind of thing. And so
that that that sort of just hodgepodge way that's the heuristic sense, right? Like that heuristic sense
of this isn't a rigorous process that you got to go steps one through five it's like it depends on the
situation. To me, in terms of the heuristics, what that always does is it just installs at the level
of the subject and choice the metaphysics it just shifts it away from the tools and into the subject
so now I've got it now I've got to choose which things I'm going to use and it's the same kind of
move and so I think that is a critical like I think and I guess I maybe I've just been trained enough
by Derrida to the extent that I share that I'm just like yeah that whole bricoleur notion only has
value as it's not an engineer it's not a scientist it's not a methodologist but if those science
engineers and methodologists are just variations of brick allure the very concept of brick allure
as as some sort of method becomes like it just loses its value and so like and that's that sense
of where and I get this later on it's like hey you know Lévi-Strauss you can call your mythic your
discourse on myths you can call it a myth and you can say it has no heightened epistemic value
and he does that like Lévi-Strauss does that it's like look my analysis of myths is not in any
Transcendent relation it's just another myth, but it's like, sure, doesn't sound like it, all of the
aspects you can't just call your thing not a you know, not knowledge and call it a myth and if you
don't pose the question I mean that's what he says he never poses the questions of the relationship
between the myth theme and the philosophy which is how do the how does an epistemic knowledge-based
sentence work with a mythical sentence and unless this is where the Amazon recommendation would pop
up if Derrida was writing contemporary like in our contemporary moment uh if you like uh structure
sign and play and my take on on Lévi-Strauss's the myth theme and the philosophy read White mythology
right right right I mean it it really is and and of course there's no salute I mean that's the other
part there's no solution to that problem right it's not like okay once I've worked through the myth
you know knowledge relationship then I can go ahead and go back and do my anthropology because I mean I
think that at some level what what would happen were Lévi-Strauss to have done that is that anthropology
would go away but that's precisely the demonstration of the non-escapability of metaphysics is to like
even even even the desire the move to try to claim the non-privileged place is privileging
non-privileged over privilege right right it's sort of like you yeah it's like a false modesty
a little bit it's sort of like the bricolars of pretentious concept because like you're saying John
it installs the engineer at the level of the subject position where I've engineered the bricolore to be
this like sort of collage artist right where you're still doing the same kind of work you know right
that's that's where Lévi-Strauss is doing that as sincerely as he possibly can like he's doing
everything he can to create this non-privileged place it's like fuck yeah I can't do it yeah yeah and
you get it I get it I mean that's that's another one of those where like I get that impulse which is
I want to undermine the kind of transcendent knowledge claims that my discourse is making
like I feel that way all the time right I want to say and you know I do it through jokes and I do it
through other like you know this is just one dumbass perspective like that's my mechanism for doing that
it's trying to undermine that what you perceive to be the status that's kind of transcendent status of
any kind of knowledge or truth claim and it's just I mean I think Derrida's point is it it has to get
built into the thing like you can't just do a scientific study and say hey this isn't science
this is just a myth on myths that doesn't change anything the sheer declaration of it ignores the
structural ways in which for instance in his case like the whole thing is set up such that future
knowledge could invalidate or alter or build upon Lévi-Strauss's so if if your whole discourse still
works like science calling it a myth just makes you feel better like that's the only thing that
you're accomplishing or even further the declaration doesn't hide that the declaration instantiates that
in a very particular way well that's even yeah that's even stronger yeah yeah right um but this is this
is the question that that arose for me reading this and thinking a whole lot I mean because basically
we're talking about a very specific struggle of trying to imagine trying to do away with the notion
of transcendent um uh like a metaphysical transcendence that creates a place of privilege
to fix knowledge as a top-down operation yeah and you know this goes back to the first few pages about
like in other words like trying to imagine structure without a center right what would it be if we didn't
have the sort of non this quasi non-structural um uh element that controls the rest of the structure
that turns play into a game in other words right with it's sort of like it's rules and then you know
you can follow any number of thinkers to say that like you know the thing about a game is that the um
the rules have to maintain outside of the play of the game and therefore they're not structured by
the game themselves they have to just be asserted they have to be just um assumed and that is the
mythological um assertion or the metaphorical assertion of uh the premise of then setting up the rest of the
structure it's like well shit I don't want to just assert something and then build on top of it I want the
firm foundation I want or I want to be able to follow the play of the structure and a whole lot
of this to me is just a matter of like here's um an interesting alliance that I don't think that
we particularly recognize as an alliance that we just think of as being self-identical
is the relationship between hierarchy and verticality that hierarchies are always vertical
that which I mean obviously hierarchy right but that that in order to declare a hierarchy or um
or order to declare a center a center you have to imagine a vertical um uh dimension to ontology that
part of it is sort of stepping outside or off off of the ontological grid in order to govern that which
is below and so the central question for me and it's one that I turn to Nietzsche and to Deleuze to think is
not just how do you imagine a flattened plane of an ontology but how do you imagine a horizontal
a flat sense of hierarchy and this is where the language of Nietzsche's appropriation makes a whole
lot of sense to me because you know it because it allows for the transcendent universalizing function
of the hierarchical claim to operate on a flat grid because even as it claims transcendence even as
it claims universality it can only sort of like disseminate out on a flat plane and grab this and
grab that remake this remake that but it has to actually do the work of doing half of its of its
spread and then in doing the work of its spread it's remaking itself at the same time so so it's like I
mean to use the terminology I think we did this last time or two times ago but like I mean the simplest
bumper sticker version of that is hypotaxis is are always paratactic paratactically installed and so
but that's the interesting question so what what's the difference between parataxis paratactically
installed and parataxis hypotactically installed you know what I mean like what what's the given that
they're both paratactic they are just both sort of serial performative instantiations what allows
for some things to congeal paratactically in a way that makes them function like their hypotaxis
well I would say rendering it that way really makes those distinctions a matter of intensity and you
can never be able you never point to one being the other because in some important ways you could say
all parataxis has uh hypotactic tendencies some absolutely you know paratactically deployed
things like they have greater or lesser affinities and it's easier for one same claim to dominate
another claim you're right we're right back at de-territorialization and re-territorialization
like that's right where we are yeah there's not one without there's not one without the other you
don't get to a pure parataxis yeah I've been saving this for like the last three episodes but I think
it's finally right for me to bring it back is that because I'm rereading the dank and dialogue
Heidegger file ones and you know we're in the first several episodes we're really well I think the
whole season we're really trying to grapple in both positive and negative ways with Heidegger's
sense of essence and um a few weeks ago I was rereading Deleuze's book on Nietzsche and De
Deleuze's um uh articulation of Nietzsche's sense of essence and you know this is all about like there
is like um uh force can only act on force and that and so there's only ever active force that provokes
the reactivity of whatever force it is appropriating and you can imagine that as a hierarchy you know on
on the on a flat uh terrain it's like but this is what I love about Nietzsche's sense of essence
is that an essence isn't something innate isn't something self-identical it's certainly not
something self-identical is that we can say that the essence of an object is only um uh is only
the forces that have appropriated it well because any force can appropriate any object right but that
doesn't but not in the object is already but the object is already constituted by force so it's
the object is already constituted by force right so there's no object there's no Ding an sich that has
not already been appropriated but some forces have a greater affinity in their appropriation of the
thing and some things the object resists more because of it and again whenever like it's hard to hear like
the object but when we think about whenever you say the objects just substitute the object for an
entire history or an entire genealogy constellation force having appropriated a force of yeah like it's
an entire genealogy of or history of of forces having appropriated each other right that in some ways
create a little bit of a knot or a little bit of like well that's what that's what I've always said
that's what an that's what an object is an object is just the historical con like congealing of force
relations yeah and but you know like given any so let's take my body as an object and we'll just say
that it is a genealogy of of forces acting upon forces that you could trace for the existence of what
we'd recognize that we call my body and another level we could call it you know trace it as the
the recognizable history of something called the human and another level the recognizable history
of what we call life whatever right but given the particular sort of like genealogy and composition
and constellation of forces that are operating on each other some forces are more likely to take hold
of my body and reshape it and other ones my body has more of an allergic reaction to and fights off
and that at least following Deleuze that's that's essence which also like which is an interesting
Sense of essence in that it's like what what is where are the great, where do the greatest affinities
lie, and where there's that kind of like where that that convergence is is most likely. That's that's
what you would call an essence. But then necessarily that essence has to change as it undergoes its
genealogical right series of half essence is mutable. Yeah, exactly right right. There's no content to an essence
only a form or a trajectory or a series of affiliations and forces which ties back into
Derrida's argument here when he's talking about the universal right it's like we're we're captured
universally by contingent circumstances I think that's kind of what he means at one point
but for Levy Strauss right when he's talking about our being captured by metaphysics like this is an
absolute necessity um but for Strauss for Levy Strauss there's still a content to the universal
right which is still within the dynamics of like nature or human nature or biological nature even in
his attempt to de-center that opposition between nature and culture there's still a fundamental
privileging of the natural right in in in his uh in his estimation right so there's a content uh to the
essence of human nature whereas for Derrida this would only be like a series of contingent
circumstances that have you know piled upon each other right um and but that's that's one of the
things first off thank you for bringing us back to Derrida because i was i was i i like shot us to the moon
you're like no no no no you were all into Deleuze Deleuze but but that's one of the things where it
kind of comes back to stuff that we were talking about last time but like that's where to me like
if what we mean by contingency right is just relation you know sort of relationality and that
relationality can accrete over time so for instance what you were saying there it's like
my body has certain you know um it's it's available to certain kind of forces and it's less available
uh to other kinds of forces recognizing full well that given one particular interaction it might become
more available to those things than it wasn't available to before so um i mean i guess the question
then uh really thinking about contingency in that sense is just like only theoretically is everything
contingent like actually in practice things are very locally and narrowly contingent to the point where
you're like why do we even fucking call it contingent right like it's in that sense it's it's not it's
like available it's it's capable of being affected in a relatively narrow series of potential circumstances
right like and so that and it's like if you just rethink what we mean by contingency then the whole
contingency universality problem goes away right it's no longer that's no longer the question of
contingency the question of contingency is relative specificity of interactions yeah right it's like
here these things are capable of some kinds of things of course you never know that until you experiment
with them it's not like you can diagnose it and just say ah i've become aware of this because
thinking itself is part of part of those you know relations but it's like so that's a sense in which
you can still claim it's not contingent although it is contingent I mean it's it's broadly contingent in the
sense that what he's saying he says this is not a historical this is a historical necessity necessity right
but but that's not a universality right like that doesn't have to be a question of universality
you're just saying certain types of contingencies are simply more available uh than others so it's like
Levy Strauss isn't the one who fucked up with a performative contradiction but but what i'm not
saying is that everyone always for all time will be stuck in metaphysics because again like that's
this is my anthropocentrism i guess like there are just different ways of thinking like and and the one
that worked for us at this juncture yeah you're trapped and we got to own the being trapped and
again i see myself now heading back to my Nietzsche argument of overcoming the human and yada yada yeah
but i mean like the necessity there is you're right it's not universal it's not transcendent it is in
some ways it is contingently necessary in so far as like hey one ethnocentric metaphysics is sort of like
uh um uh operates by through its attempt to totalize binaries and the totalization of those binaries is
inescapable from like in the terrain that it inaugurates the escape the escape of those binaries
is impossible but as it plays out you know at some contingent point or another but necessarily at a point
you know it starts to recognize its own uh its own complicity its own incapacity to do this and be
and has always harbored in the necessity of its own critique and so like if there's a way out of it
it's not for an individual or a human or the human to get out of metaphysics it's for metaphysics to
become something else right that's right right it would be in it yeah like metaphysics has to become
Unrecognizable to itself, it's not like it can't be that some people are in it and some people are out
of it; it would be an epochal shift, not like the intentions of one individual to be like, I have driven
past metaphysics. It would be a complete shift, a transmutation in our mode of relating, which is like
what Nietzsche was after. And this is like Derrida's point here, that we are, that this is a an historical
necessity. It reminds me a little bit of Hegel's concrete universality, which I think touches on what you both
were just saying, yeah, which is that you are universally enthralled to contingent circumstances
right? So that contingency holds weight and sediments over years, and that's how we get metaphysics and
ethnocentrism. So of course you can imagine other ways of being, but the historical fact is that we're all
at least in the West sort of caught up, right? And that's what I don't like about contingency, I think, is
it's it's it's this kind of leveling thing, like it treats it's it's like a such a homogenizing concept.
And I think that's what I'm going after, is like contingency, like not all contingency is equal, right?
It would be one way of saying it, like to call it, to insist upon the contingency of something is to say
that everything is is available, tends to be that everything is available depending on the circumstances.
And it's like, no, that's the point: not everything is available, right? Like, yeah, um, and they're still
contingent and and i i would grant that like it's still everything is available but but like the
condition only theoretically only well yeah but like but also practically as well it's just that
the possibility that the sorts of the conditions that would you know have to align in just the right
way for some things to happen would be astronomically unlikely. I mean, right? So let's just say they can't
happen just very rarely. But let's just take Nietzsche's example of Christianity, right? Like, so Christianity
is a formation that has tends to be about resentment, right? Like, that that's that's just the sort of
way the reactive forces that that could you know is it imaginable to think i mean is it imaginable to think of a
religion of affirmation? I think Nietzsche's gonna say no, it's not imaginable to think of a religion of
affirmation. It's not imaginable for active force itself, you know, it's not becoming reactive, right?
Like, it's just it can't do that, it's it's not available for that. Is it hypothetically available
in some hyper futuristic thing with it? Of course, like who knows where you'd have to all those terms
will have will have to have shifted, will have to have shifted, like the same thing with like a square
circle? I can't imagine a square circle, but you know, I mean, I suppose within an entirely different
apparatus that different geometry, yeah, different geometry, then you know, that becomes not so like
once we have five six seven dimensions, you know, who knows, right? Like maybe we find that circles are
essentially related to to triangles, I don't know. Oh, but only in the sixth dimension, that's the issue for
me. I think with i mean even though in many ways i'm like i'm totally in favor of the term it's just
that it feels like because it's negotiating its relationship to universality I feel like
you know yeah yeah the the insistence on that particular dyad I want to i just kind of want to
say like contingency isn't really i mean i just think i keep coming back to the phrasing and i think
it's in What Is Philosophy? where Deleuze is like contingency is only contingent to itself
and that actually makes sense to me, right? Like, it's it's not contingent upon something, it's
contingent upon contingency, right? You know, and i'm like, okay, I got that because that gives me a
meatier sense of continuous as opposed to saying, hey, stuff's contingent, it's like not really. I mean,
I mean, it's the way that i've been using it. I feel like is kind of in line with Derrida's argument
where it's sort of more of a, it's sort it's a cultural or, you know, historical argument where
it's it's about inherited presuppositions, right? So like if you're contingently affected by a series
of presuppositions and you're not, you know, critically reflective upon that then you can uh sort of lean
in the Lévi-Strauss direction or you can you know aspire to an empirical study of of human being, right?
Because you think you've gotten outside of this circle, so contingency actually functions as a warning
in that case of our being in debt to a series of very specific relations, right? So it's not about just
wide open anything can happen, right? It's about like you are directly affected by a constellation of
concepts and ideals and motives that you're not necessarily or ever aware of, you know, but I mean
think of the claim like this necessity is irreducible, it is not a historical contingency
it's not like it's not his story. I mean he's not even saying it's a subjective contingency, which is
obvious it's not just Lévi-Strauss an individual but it's like it's not even a historical contingency
It's not like because of the era in which he lived, uh, he's he's making the choice that he's making, well
I mean imagine the best way of trying to contradict that and say like, okay, well, once Western metaphysics
is installed then it's a necessity, but Western metaphysics didn't have to be installed but then
you realize or maybe it maybe it didn't get installed would be the next level of the claim, like you know
that there isn't a Western metaphysics. Well, I mean that that that's another thing. I mean like I want to
get that. Okay, set that side. Sorry. Okay, uh, just be because that's that's a beef I have with both
ethnology and ethnocentrism, but um, but to go back to this for a second, um, you would have to imagine like
okay what would it be to imagine a history without Western metaphysics, right, like history in terms of
in terms but you couldn't even consider that word history, yeah, historia like has is very indebted to
a metaphysical it makes no sense without, yeah. What would it even like fuses? Yeah, what? Yeah, like the
way prehistory is distinctly not history, right, and so yeah, so that would like even that way would fail
like that's that's why the necessity is insofar as there is a history that history is necessitated
to universalize itself, yes, right. The universalizing force of history is
is necessarily takes itself up and critiques itself. Well, and and the reason also that this extends beyond
Lévi-Strauss and ethnography is just that you're going to be caught up in something, so even if it
weren't Western metaphysics, which it happens to be, you would still have inherited presuppositions
somehow or another, right, so like you're going to be caught up in the game and you're going to be
you're going to have some sort of floating unconscious that's that's motivating your decisions regardless of
the historical context, right, so like you can generalize that argument away from ethnography
i think but you almost don't have to because the way the Derrida's setting it up, ethnocentrism is
universalizing in itself
yeah, yeah, you're going to feast on this one. Conceptuality is something other than itself
there's been a change in the image of thought. That's what it is. That's what it is
that's what it is. The internal structure of book as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth
it's divorced from the subject